[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an episode from an american
adult animated anthology love death and
robots called the drowned giant
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
at the beginning of the episode three
scientists drive to a beach while one of
them named steven narrates about a naked
dead giant
the day before a massive storm had hit
the sea which washed up a dead body of a
giant to the shore the surprised local
fishermen contacted the officials who at
first refused to believe such atrocious
news but as people began to visit the
beach and return home with crazy stories
the scientists decided to go see for
themselves and so steven and his
colleagues who thought that everyone was
just bluffing about the dead giant now
stand before him a crowd surrounds the
corpse scared to touch it before being
absolutely sure that it's safe steven's
colleagues guess that the man weighs
somewhere around 80 tons stephen
narrates that the vast proportion of his
features makes it difficult for them to
figure out his age but looking at the
giant's defined nose and mouth he
believes that he had been a young man
with a modest temper the three go around
the giant's body inspecting him stephen
sees a pool of water that had been
collected in the corpse's palm where
tiny fishes swim stephen says that
beyond the size of the giant the simple
fact that he exists surprises him the
most he compares the giant's existence
to the crowd on the beach and concludes
that they are just imperfect and puny
copies of him as steven looks at the
creature mesmerized his colleague climbs
on top of the corpse's chest and waves
towards the crowd indicating that it is
safe to come near it the people run
towards him while cheering and climb up
on top some of them comment that the
body is rubbery and bouncy children
start playing on his chest trashing it
with their shoes steven however doesn't
touch or climb on it he and his
colleagues stare at the giant from afar
while writing their notes as time passes
by the people get enough of playing with
the dead giant and everyone returns home
after three days stephen visits the
beach again because of his growing
interest in the giant his facility
assigns him the role of keeping tabs on
it steven claims that he wasn't morbid
about keeping an eye on a dead person
because for him the giant was more alive
than the people around him he watches
his kids play slide on the corpse's
chest and some workers plan to butcher
his femur bone the following day steven
deliberately postponed his visit to the
beach until late afternoon so that no
one would be around when he gets there
the corp looks in bad form and has
started to decay a teenage girl sits
comfortably on the giant's ear using it
as a chair steven notices that the
giant's face has a much less youthful
look than it had before he assumes it is
because of prolonged immersion in sea
water and tomb a faction of tissue as a
crab crawls out of the giant's mouth the
scientist claims that it won't be long
until he decays fully
steven finally gets the courage to set
foot on the corpse atop his chest he
sees a sandcastle someone had built then
his other arm comes into view showing us
that half of it has already decayed and
whatever remained of it has been taken
away by the people
meanwhile his cornea has become hazy and
cloudy which gives his eyes a whirlpool
effect
steven looks at them saying that the
giant's suffering is less tragic than
this isolation that he is facing the
next time he visits the giant both of
his arms and one of his legs have
decayed and been cut steven walks around
looking at the corpse which has been
vandalized by teens who spray paint
insults on his body he is reluctant to
witness the end of the magnificent
creature but the insults make him feel
that the creature is more human because
it seems more vulnerable to him now when
stephen comes to the beach the following
day he is almost relieved to see that
the corpse's head has been removed
birds eat its flesh as steven watches it
from afar without the head the corpse
looked less human which reduces steven's
relationship with the corpse that he had
formed
after that day he doesn't visit the
beach for a few weeks
on his next journey he witnesses that
any feature indicating that the corpse
was once human has vanished the only
thing that remains is the decaying gut
of the once magnificent creature by now
the interest of the crowd in the giant
has expired
months later after the giant's arrival
has been forgotten various pieces of his
body can be seen around town especially
his bones which are used as decorations
while cycling one day stephen notices
the giant's skull lying abandoned he
believes that if he looks around the
town's pubs he will find mummified noses
and ears as well
according to stephen these decorations
convey the giant's greatness better than
steven's memory of his bloated and
decaying appendages as for the giant's
genitals it is shown that it had been
cut off and placed in the freak museum
in a circus
steven narrates that the apparatus
occupies a whole tent to itself but is
sadly mislabeled as belonging to a whale
at last the scientist says that the
people who saw the giant remember him
only as a sea monster
however for him the giant is still alive
and he often dreams of his resurrection
in his dreams the giant strides through
the town picking up his fragments on his
return journey to the sea
the episode although short has a deep
and metaphorical meaning in every scene
the fans of the episode have interpreted
it their own way but many believe that
the narrator stephen is the giant
himself steven feels the pain of the
dead giant when no one else can so some
fans think that stephen and the giant
are the same person the giant might be
trying to communicate through steven
moreover the waist even describes
several stages of the decaying of the
corpse in such detail makes one wonder
if he is the one going through the
stages the decaying of the giant's
corpse is also seen as a metaphor for
several things the narrator stephen
observes the decaying of the corpse very
closely at every stage first he sees the
process that was supposed to happen that
is his body decaying by the passage of
time then he notices people starting to
amputate the corpse treating it as a
commodity and the way humans treat him
poorly showed him the extent of
consumerism and exploitation that is
considered normal in today's world as
the story progresses stephen begins to
question what it means to be human and
when do we decide that we have lost
humanity
until the corpse had no head he thought
of it as a human just like him and the
others around him in fact he believed
that the giant was more of a human than
tiny creatures like himself however
after steven's sympathy towards the
giant dropped when he saw him only as a
mass of flesh
throughout the episode we do not know
who the giant is or where he came from
rather the drowned giant focuses more on
the contrast of steven and other
people's feelings towards the giant in
the book itself jg ballard concludes
with the detail about the giant's
appendage being displayed in a circus
this is to emphasize how much the giant
was humiliated even though he possessed
a greater existence than them all it
also denotes human's superficial and
exploitative nature
moreover his genitals were labeled to be
of a whales and his bones were mere
decorations for the people here it is
clear that the giant has been completely
stripped of his humanity
however steven describes the genitals
and decorated bones as the only things
that convey how magnificent of a being
the giant was although he loves and
remembers the creature more than anyone
else he believes that his memory of his
decaying body would have never conveyed
his greatness the way his preserved body
parts do the giant was just a myth
before being washed up to the shore
people experienced his arrival for a
short while but forgot about him soon
turning his existence into a myth once
again
we humans like the giant will someday
fade away and remain only in the
memories of the people we met
but eventually those memories will fade
as well and we simply cease to exist
boy that got dark
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching